It's really hard to see three billion letters
stretched out and running across the screen or
in books, but you can very easily see
all the DNA packed into a cell, because it's
organized into these neat structures called chromosomes. This is a picture
actual chromosomes from a cell that was dividing. Inside each cell
you have a total human genome inside, and it's organized into chromatin,
which is organized even further into these chromosomes
structures that you see here. Now I want you
to see if you can do, is tell me how many chromosomes do you think you see
here? See if you can count the total
number of chromosomes and enter that number into the
box here. If you have trouble counting, don't
get frustrated. Just move on to the solution video.